I know you worked with the designer
Johnny I've on helping to design even
these chairs and balls and everything in
here how did that collaboration work it
was multiple so so yes his his vision
and his his incredible attention to
details that said I've been Oh being
being in a probably the greatest
industrial designer in the world ever
but then we also have a firm in London
Foster and partners so that that worked
very closely with Sir Johnny I've on the
campus so it was actually a combination
we also wanted a lot of the elements the
hardware the architecture in the new
store design to come right from the
campus be it floors and walls or all of
the new stools so so a lot of the
elements we pulled in order to get that
synergy get that when you say the campus
you mean the new new Apple Park oh so a
lot of the stuff that's in new Apple
Park is brought now into the stores Oh
explain what about what else besides so
you have these balls in the campus not
that we don't have we don't have a forum
in the campus you don't have the cubes
and the balls and the those were
specifically things that that that
Foster and partners and in so Johnny
designed together
I'm exclusively for the stores but but
the materials you know a lot of the
furniture in the boardroom is taken
right out of a meeting room from campus
sir Johnny I've is is famously versed to
selling anything are you in that camp I
mean do you tell people in the store to
sell you're gonna get me in trouble with
my boss okay okay you know it's funny
no I tell them to serve write it in and
if you give incredible service and if
you are very present and you are taking
care of someone then that will be the
outcome whether it's that moment whether
it's a week later whether it's online
enough in another country when that
tourist goes home so you know is it a
hard absolutely not I think it's educate
serve be
for every individual for whatever their
needs are and then I believe that comes
back to you tenfold